let's hear from people in the audience
we do this via discord you can find our
discord davidpakman.com
slash discord we are going to start
today
with jess in florida jess in florida
welcome
hello hello you're on the air
oh hey hi david uh if you can hear me
okay let's get into it so i have a
question
a couple questions regarding like
research literacy
okay um
i think that
as people as americans we would probably
have an easier time solving problems if
we all had a sort of like foundation on
what the problems are right
and also not only that if we could have
an agreement as to what's a fact and
what's an opinion
exactly yes absolutely yep and i you
know i had other questions regarding
like holy texts and what that has to do
with it but getting to the point here i
was wondering uh what what your thoughts
are on uh
on
you know creating research literacy
classes in grade schools to sort of help
this on a long term scale um
how would we do that like what could
that potentially look like and what can
people
listeners of yours who aren't teachers
or politicians do to help enact
something like that beautiful so first
and foremost the answer is yes i've
never used the term research literacy
but i've talked about bringing
epistemology critical thinking and media
literacy into every classroom starting
in i i would say at the latest in fifth
grade now how do we do it how do we do
it the the difficulty is
it's basically determined at the state
level right curricula determined at the
state level overlapping with
municipalities under seen by overseen
rather by individual superintendents etc
so
the way to do this is we need activists
going to school board meetings
everywhere in order to request this
you've got to lobby the state boards of
education
and local municipalities and i'm not
saying go and behave the way the
anti-mass people behave at the school
board meetings but we need a concerted
effort to say we need media literacy
critical thinking and epistemology
coursework how do we
why do we believe the things we believe
starting no later than fifth grade and
it's going to take a lot of local
activism
yeah as um as a younger person i
graduated high school in 2016. okay and
the only time i ever got any sort of
research training was like
how to use a library you know what i
mean we need to learn how to
like figure out what's true and what's
not true on the internet that's so
important absolutely absolutely jess
you've said it beautifully can i ask
what part of florida you're in
gainesville obligatory go gators that's
a that's a pretty uh red area if i
understand correctly it is and i have to
deal with it all the time but not for
long because i'm moving to oregon where
people wear masks beautiful beautiful
all right jess thank you so much for the
call
thanks so much bye-bye david all right
just from florida in gainesville for now
but not for long
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
bioavailable ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good helps me get everything i'm trying
to get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.com pacman the link is in
the podcast notes